once a month social workers from Hong
Kong charity group chicken soup
Foundation paid Michelle Nye a visit at
her home
Michelle is a single mother struggling
to get by on a meager income in one of
the world's most expensive cities she
can barely afford the basics for her and
her autistic daughter
the tables and chairs in her home were
donated by the charity
to other people they may be ordinary
things but to me and my daughter it
makes us feel fortunate that somebody
shows us love
chicken soup Foundation mainly supports
single parent families providing
counseling as well as Necessities
including medical supplies
this washing machine was also a recent
donation
since the start of the covid-19 pandemic
many of Hong Kong's poorest are facing
unprecedented hardship
seeing people face such difficulty has
an emotional effect on us too
over the last three years there's been a
big rise in people seeking relief for
charity workers it's been particularly
demanding I see some burnout on staff
there especially during the fifth wave
because at that time we have more than
50 percent of our staff got covered as
well but we still have to serve our
families and that's not the only reason
many Charities are facing Staffing
challenges according to the Hong Kong
social workers General Union as many as
28 of social workers quit their jobs in
the last year many of them left the city
all together because of strict pandemic
curves and political uncertainty forming
a Crackdown on the pro-democracy
movement
Hong Kong's struggling economy as a
result of the pandemic has made
fundraising more difficult also one
survey conducted by a local agency found
a fifth of the organizations that
interviewed had shuttered or suspended
operations
is a platform for the people to help the
society to do good you know for the
community so without this platform I
think there will be a full opportunity
for the people in Hong Kong to to have a
channel to to you know to do good for
this society and the loss of such
organizations means many who have been
struggling here and rely on their help
will find it difficult to get the
support they need Patrick fock Al
Jazeera Hong Kong